household being on house arrest that  [ __ ] that [ __ ] kept a [ __ ] focused for  real like i ain't gonna lie like that  [ __ ]  had me on my program like i couldn't do  number go to the house and go to the  studio because that was my job you  feeling me so that's all [ __ ] doing so  as soon as i get off this [ __ ] i'm out  that business i'll probably get when i  get up like  a month and a half or something  yeah i probably got off like a month and  a half ago like my program instead of  saying like i'm on house arrest like i  go to the studio and i go home like you  saying me like i feel it like like then  so you're still kind of on that routine  even though i'm still now routine that  should be psyching me out sometimes like  damn like yeah i can't go cause i'm oh  wait like this is really what i want to  do all day like if it's a it's a good  feeling though